[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était vraiment plus
âgé que moi je suis tout bêtement
trouver dans ses bras
par lui j'ai découvert je connaissais
pas il semblait
sincère je l'aimais pour ça
ce qui m'a toujours dérangé et correment
le soir je pouvais le capter mais dès
qu'il me parlaient
cela permet tout le monde
[Musique]
je voyais déjà
je n'avais plus de vie je ne pensais
qu'à lui même si j'ai cramé que souvent
il manquait
se perdez dans ce qui me racontait se
tromper non quand il disait qu'il
m'aimait et je supportais
je pars toutes les dans sa cage j'ai
trouvé des jouets j'ai grillé que
continuer de l'appeler mais qu'est-ce
qu'il
y a
[Musique]
trop je ne voyais déjà
Samir dans ses bras il avait des mots
je ne savais pas
je ne connaissais pas il a je suis vite
Jésus mais de chercher un chien de
compagnie [ __ ] de maison on s'imagine
tout de suite la vie de famille pendant
tout ce temps j'étais dans quoi j'étais
dans le fond j'étais dans ma surprise
elle est tout de suite venue m'avouer
j'étais pas la première comme avec
s'amuser pendant que moi j'étais
[Musique]
Il avait les mots croisés
je savais pas je le connaissais pas
il avait les mots
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci merci merci
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
en concert au Zénith et oui de Paris le
5 février
[Applaudissements]
vraiment à le dire depuis des années je
t'adore et je suis toujours avec toi
au zénith et c'est incroyable et c'est
un super cadeau mais je tiens quand même
à notifier que Cyril et une des seules
personnes de télé qui ne m'a jamais
oublié que ce soit en haut en bas au
milieu moins bien
donc important de noter
[Applaudissements]
faut que tu reviennes nous voir
avec plaisir j'ai plus besoin
et franchement et nous si tu es toujours
la bienvenue chez nous tu sais c'est
voilà même nous on t'aime tu es
magnifique et franchement j'adore cette
fille depuis des années c'est vraiment
une copine et voilà je t'adore
merci d'avoir été là